the fourth final destination opens with
a race car accident so as you can
imagine the scene is loaded up with
references
and easter eggs hidden in the many
advertisements plastered on the cars
around the speedway the car that was
responsible for the accident was car six
each opening disaster in the previous
movies has referenced hell or the devil
from almost any given angle you can see
three sixes on the car representing the
devil's number and the hellfire decals
represents the fiery inferno this car
has a number of adds on it including
brand x the same brand of vehicle that
would eventually take out the mechanic
andy there's also a brand x racing
poster in the security guard's office
there are lots of
x's in this movie the goth hair stylist
didi has an x tattoo on her arm
the main character nick has an xbox and
the characters hunt and janet are
ex-boyfriend and girlfriend the
recurring exes may be an homage to the
special effects company that did most of
the effects on this movie
another decal scene on this car and many
of the others is this one for heck race
chefs
created by ryan heck the assistant art
director there's also a banner for
hecarecius where we see their slogan
performance get it in gear nick has a
premonition later on where his
girlfriend lori is grinded up by an
escalator gear
there's also some text on the car's hood
feel the rush which could be a sign
about the violent stampede out of the
stadium when the crash first occurs
that's just the first car in the first
scene there is so
much more and i'll be covering it all so
stick around
to the end of this video
directorial duties for the final
destination would for some reason be
turned back over to final destination
2's director david r ellis and he didn't
really innovate a whole lot
last time he brought us the route 23
pileup so this time the opener is
another pile up but this time it's at a
race track aside from that there's
definitely
a miscommunication about the tone of the
franchise between these two directors
long's movies kind of have some
emotional depth to the characters while
ellis seems entirely focused on goofy
over-the-top kills it's easy to
understand why huang was promoted to the
director's chair as a writer and ellis's
background was as a stunt coordinator
one thing that they did get down between
the two of them was lots of things you
missed
but before we get back into them this is
my last raycon ad read of the year so
let's go back over some of the best
moments
like when i told you all of the reasons
that you should pick up ray cons
you'll get six hours of play time
seamless bluetooth powering more bass a
more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit
and that time i told you if they make a
good holiday gift or not
they make a great holiday gift because
you can use them anytime anywhere
so many great raycon memories and
there's about to be an even greater one
raycon's being generous for the holidays
they're offering all of my viewers
fifteen percent off right now
click the link in the description box or
go to buy raycon.com's world to get 15
percent off your recon purchase
[Music]
the first thing you'll hear when you
start watching the final destination is
the song devour by shine down
unlike previous movies there isn't a
diegetic death omen song that is one
that the characters can hear but the
lyrics are still kind of relevant like
this line smash it and crash it and
thrash it and trash it you know they're
only toys
there would soon be a lot of smashing
and crashing and we do see a toy version
of the main car involved in that crash
later on at the mall when our characters
would walk by the megatech booth
remember the race that ended in tragedy
was called the megatech 300
and that race was held at the mckinley
speedway i pointed out the meaning
behind that name and the many locations
with the mckinley moniker in my final
destination 3 video let's look at some
of the other cars involved in the race
most of these appear on multiple cars or
in multiple places in the stadium so
i'll just be mentioning where i first
noticed each one the red car 71 has a
phone number on it which contains the
number 180 a reference to flight 180
from the first movie the characters are
also sitting in section 180 in the
stands
tell me again why we chose this
overseeing the movie they do end up
seeing the movie later this is a clue
about another one of the disasters car
51 is a red and white vehicle with lots
of stickers this one says hanahan sht
taylor representing executive producer
sheila hanahan's halo
beck tires is probably a nod to the set
designer jeffrey beck
jb dupuy is named after the foreman
james dupuy hey look it's me
trying to watch this movie car 456 is a
grey and black vehicle with a big
sponsorship from bill wall weather
this is a clue about the disaster
because we saw billboard leather back in
final destination 2
on the shortly worn shirt of evan lewis
moments before his accident
andy is also wearing a bill wall shirt
this car also has ads for casey moore
gasoline named after production
secretary casey moore belcastro
performance ignition after production
executive dana belcastro and bernard
helmets after director's assistant kim
bernard the pit stop guys have patches
that say wolf cans as i mentioned in the
last episode wolves are a mongolian sign
of good luck
car 16 is the bubbly blue car with a
sticker that simply says colin grant
that's the name of the storyboard artist
there's also a vinnitski synthetic oil
after post-production supervisor jay
vanitsky gladder tires after supervising
production coordinator emily glatter and
layman something after associate
producer tawny ellis layman
that's one of the director's daughters
the overall design of this car could be
our clue about the accident that nearly
took janet's life at the car wash on the
back there's an ad for holmberg
industries named after production
manager eric holmberg car 71 says
matthew's on the back there's a stunt
man named eddie matthews he's probably
the one driving that car
is it safe to sit here of course there's
a fence there we're fine
i guess it's kind of a good thing that
this line is at the beginning of the
movie because i still have the stanima
to hear stupid stuff like that
so i'm actually going to let this one
slide the trailers offer a couple more
connections like coleman exhaust named
after art coordinator sarah holman
and dashnaw named after the second unit
director jeffrey dashnaw the spilled oil
could be a callback to this part from
the first movie
one of the warning signs is when nick
discovers that they're actually at a
memorial event for all of the past
drivers who had passed away like the
flight 180 memorial most of them are
named after crew members with the
exception of these five
in the stands i noticed a woman with a
blue white and red striped dress
reminiscent of the french flag
we've seen this pattern a lot because
the original final destination was
supposed to be paris france
other paris references in the movie
include this french-style scooter in the
cafe the very idea of a cafe
is french and also a callback to the
first movie the picture of the eiffel
tower and nick's apartment
this advertisement at the cleaners is a
sideways french flag lordy has this idea
about her and nick's future plans
lots of traveling like paris maybe some
beaches
and george gets hit by an ambulance with
blue white and red stripes just like
terry cheney was struck down by the bus
in the first movie he also compares the
premonitions to the feeling of deja vu
just like wendy did in fd3
no no no not that it's like deja vu my
wife said that deja vu
is like god's way
the name of the cafe that nick lori
janet and hunt like to hang out at is
death by caffeine and this is the
location where three out of the four of
them eventually meet their fate
next door there's a tattoo psychic
parlor psychics are often referenced in
the franchise as the main character of
each movie has a psychic premonition
about a potential danger the items on
the menu are potential warning signs
that death is coming for them the
examples i could see were knocking on
death store latte
deadly espresso macchiato iced mocha
fatality ice vanilla demise frozen chai
casualties last exit truffles which are
maybe a reference to final destination
2's highway pileup river of styx
biscotti a reference to the mythological
boundary between our world and hell
afterlife muffins and iced fudge ripple
rip stands for rest in peace
the coffee cup logo seen here is also
the same logo seen at the coffee beanery
from final destination one both
locations have somebody getting hit by a
large commercial vehicle there's also a
heist pale ale sticker on the
refrigerator a callback to movies two
and three were these heist pale ale
trucks were involved in two of the
accidents
there was a stunt double named cassidy
heist on this one i guess stunts run in
the heist family
if you look at the closed captioning on
the tv you'll notice the news report is
posing the question
are amusement parks going the way of the
dinosaur this is probably a response to
the accident that took place on the
roller coaster devil's flights in the
previous movie which took place four
years ago
it's hard to tell but it's possible this
is the same kid who is the ride operator
maybe he's here applying for a new job
in a later scene there's a framed photo
containing an ominous sign
the words last exit nick and lori go to
the memorial for the lives lost at the
speedway there are pictures of some of
the victims including
apparently the little girl from the fire
meme
this movie continues the tradition of
having something wildly inappropriate
happening at each disaster memorial
this time it's this dude carter daniel
is just dropping an n-bomb out of
nowhere
at least i thought it was out of nowhere
until i went back and realized he
actually has a swastika tattoo in the
speedway scene
at the memorial he's wearing a necklace
it's actually very similar to evan
lewis's demon tail necklace in the
second one but this one is more of a
hook a clue about his fate which
involves him getting stuck on a hook and
dragged down the streets by his truck
that night nick sees some more signs in
his dream in the third one wendy sees
the signs in her photographs but in this
one nick
just has more premonitions which is not
that creative but one interesting thing
is how the words it's here are hidden
somewhere in each vision
in carter's it briefly appears in the
fire in samantha's it's a dark spot on a
hair straightener in andes it's obscured
by smoke in hunts it can be seen in the
draining pool water in janet's on the
inside of a pipe
and in the vision for the movie theater
victims it's in the fire
again and for nick lori and janet the
words it's coming scratched into the
table are now crossed out
because it's here another sign from that
night is this photo of nick and lori
getting stabbed by this blade that's
just sitting out which is really just
taken directly from final destination 2
but it's made
a lot less subtle this time the first
individual death is carter daniels who's
driving while sipping a can of heist
pale ale
just like the truck driver when we were
first introduced to the iconic brand of
heist
what is it about this brand that just
attracts the worst people
the trouble for him begins when the
horseshoe hanging from his mirror falls
and turns on his radio i've previously
talked about how there are horseshoes in
most of these movies as a symbol of luck
because in final destination there's a
big emphasis on luck
chance and fates all being tied together
other examples are hunt's lucky coin
that he drops before being killed
the dye on carter's locking mechanism
the boss of the auto shop having a shirt
with a horseshoe and shooting star the
brand of hairspray in the salon is
sprinkle star
and it shoots up to dislodge the ceiling
fan the homeless guy who throws away a
lucky penny and the movie that lori and
janet go to see is in theater 13 the
unlucky number the song that turns on is
why can't we be friends it almost seems
like it's supposed to be a commentary
about how carter's end is like a
punishment for being racist and not
being friends with george however if
that's the case
it doesn't really fit in with the rest
of the deaths in the series because
everyone else was innocent i guess the
other carter was kind of a bully
and a lot of the final destination 2
characters were on drugs and frankie is
just disrespectful towards women but
even these don't have any kind of lesson
learned moment like this
i just find it kind of weird that death
would take the time to basically tell
him that he should have been better but
then again he is by far the worst person
in the franchise so far
in every final destination episode i've
talked about how death uses water or
liquid in practically every attack
this movie is maybe the biggest example
the racetrack explosion started with the
spilled flammable oil carter is a victim
of a leaky gas tank samantha asked for a
glass of water
oh dee dee could i please get some water
which causes the aerosol can to slide
into the clutches of the hair
straightener these series of events at
the custom shop is set into motion with
this
janet is nearly drowned in a freak car
wash accident and hunt is actually
drowned in a freak swimming pool
accident
the cowboy is crushed by an overfilled
bathtub that falls through the ceiling
and the movie theater accident is a
result of
more leaked flammable substance that
concept is really overused the last
three characters are taken out in a
beverage shop and nick has one of his
visions next to a bus shelter ad for
clear rivers water
clear rivers is also the girl from final
destination one and two watch this
episode of horror history for her full
story and analysis
speaking of water i noticed a wild surf
poster in nick's apartment
before getting into the film business
director david r ellis was a junior pro
surfer so
this may have been a little nod to his
past life that literally no one paid
attention to
the next sign is when nick catches a
reflection of his ceiling fan in a
mirror on the coffee table a clue about
the ceiling fan that nearly fell on
samantha the komen brush tell us that
the accident occurs at a hair salon and
these rocks represent the rock that the
lawnmower accidentally propels into her
skull
i also just have to point out this
magazine which covers topics like sex
sports beer gadgets cloths cars
and sex and also nuclear sex next
location would be
the hair salon which has a hidden
connection with vuli flight 180
throughout the final destination
franchise i've pointed out several
examples of hell and demon references
the name of the hair place
salon dante refers to dante's inferno
the famous 14th century poem describing
dante alighieri's
journey through hell the next victim
samantha lane is with her two sons after
their soccer game their numbers are
twenty and nine
twenty times nine equals one eighty the
number of alex browning's infamous
flights
across the street a gardener pours fuel
into his mower one of the few fuel cans
that does not get lit on fire in the
world of final destination
based on his hat it looks like he works
for james tools and parts a reference to
the production designer james hinkle
it's not a final destination movie
without our goth girl right i love how
the salon has this big old framed photo
of a pair of scissors as if it were not
abundantly clear that they cut hair in
this establishment
another ominous sign is seen when the
soccer kids come back with slushies the
same brand that ashley and ashlynn had
before they became the latest tanning
bed victims
i've got my eye on youtube
hopefully it was the other eye this
incident seems to be an homage to what
happened to billy hitchcock in the
original final destination where a piece
of scrap metal shot out from under the
train to decapitate him
gotta love this guy's reaction though
yep just another day on the job
nick soon learns that death is one step
closer to him when he sees this article
we find out that samantha lane who the
credits fittingly list as
milf samantha is actually from lakeview
which is where the hospital was located
in final destination 2.
there are many bad omens here the ads at
the top are all about making your will
and planning your estates and the
related stories are all about other
disasters the bus trash on highway 180
references both the flight number 180
and the pile-up the following year which
took place on a highway there's also
mention of a ferris wheel disaster and
not the first one that's come up here on
things you missed either
it's probably an homage to the amusement
park crash in final destination 3.
the url of this article contains a 1-08
which is also an anagram of 180. the
author of the article is amy michelle
aiken
i'm guessing she's a relative of prop
master curtis aiken who also appears as
a golfer at the country club the article
claims that the rock was moving at light
speed
yeah i don't know about that it also
says the lawnmower guy is named danny
wall
not carl i guess he was just wearing
carl's shirt or something nick and
laurie have their friends over to try to
explain what's going on hey is that a
heist pale
oh another article tells the story of
another accident survivor named pam
smith we find out that she was once
acquainted with brian gibbons the
farmer's son who blew up in the closing
moments of final destination 2. a police
officer on the scene was rushed to
lakeview hospital and pronounced dead by
dr ellen klarjian the same doctor who
resuscitated kimberly corman
nick and laurie do everything they can
to warn them but janet and hunts are
unwilling to listen to their theories
and head for the exits
where are you going i'm gonna do what i
do best i'm gonna go get laid
wait take the magazine the scene where
that happens though is probably the most
ridiculous scene in the entire franchise
so they're in this closed off cabana at
a public pool with
little kids walking around everywhere
there are people sitting like three feet
away with the only barrier
being this fabric which is light enough
that it's just kind of blowing around in
the wind and he's literally yelling to
go faster and stuff there
is no barrier to sound right here but in
case by some
miracle nobody could hear them doing it
this chick makes it even more obvious by
putting the bikini back on
outside of the cabana
so moving on janet has a pickup from
carver's cleaners i think carver is kind
of a slasher reference she drives to the
car wash to try to clean off her
windshield and if you're paying close
attention there are several clues about
what's about to happen to her take a
look at the shape of her car
it's very boxy almost like an aquarium
and behind the steering wheel
there are a couple of small fish she
drops her quarter into the sewer grate
so she's unable to fit through to get it
she suffers a similar predicament when
she's unable to escape through the
opening in the sunroof there's also a
rubber duck in front of the passenger
seat just another clue that this tub is
gonna be filling up
anyway she does survive but she comes
out of there looking like that roblox
music video her car is picked up by
destiny towing the same towing company
that nazi carter worked for
that name by the way destiny indicates
the nature of the final destination
world where everything is a part of
death's design
back at the pool this little kid is a
super soaker called the flash flood it
makes me wonder if this is supposed to
be a reference to the big storm at the
end of the first movie i already
mentioned this when i covered fd2 but in
that movie we see a fish get caught in
the filter at the dentist office which
is a scaled down version of what happens
to hunt at the swimming pool back at
nick's house he and lori are trying to
make the place safe and we get a glimpse
of his bookshelf the first publication
in the stack is hamlet
this is technically a sign that spoiler
alert for hamlet which came out over 400
years ago everyone dies in the end
we pretty much knew that though as soon
as we saw that it's a final destination
movie however there would be some new
surprises in the final destination lore
hidden in the pages of
the newspaper
in every final destination things you
missed episode so far i've explained how
each character's name is an homage to an
important person in the horror genre
sadly in the final destination last
names weren't really
a thing but if we do some detective work
using the original script
it seems that the plan was once to
continue the tradition now i don't
really know most of the filmmakers being
referenced in this one they aren't
exactly household names but i was able
to find them and confirm their
contributions to the horror genre
because i already knew to look for
horror filmmakers thanks to the other
movies
you can just look them up if you want to
know what they did nick's last name was
o'bannon this was likely a reference to
horror writer director dan o'bannon
laurie milligan was named after andy
milligan janet cunningham seems to be
named after sean cunningham hunt
wynorsky has got to be for jim wynorski
who made a lot of b-movies and horror
parodies
i know we've seen the wind associated
with death before in this franchise but
usually there's a window open or
something and i like how it just goes
from being a light wind towards their
face to this freaking gale force in the
opposite direction but it's just
entirely targeted at this full coffee
cup like the paper and the cardboard
don't move at all but the porcelain mug
just jumps off the table the spilled
coffee stains this newspaper causing
nick to believe this is a message
because only the words through action
they were saved are left dry so he
thinks his actions could save george and
the rest of them but what he should have
been paying attention to is the contents
of this article about an out-of-control
truck crashing through a storefronts to
kill three students from mckinley high
school
this is definitely a sign about nick
lori and janet's death in the final
scene of the movie
like many others that we've learned
about in this episode they were taken to
lakeview hospital and like a couple of
previous deaths in the franchise the
driver was under the influence of
alcohol
the name of that driver was jason
kaufman a development executive on the
movie and the article was written by art
schaefer a co-producer
the other articles don't seem to be
related but they do have crew reference
easter eggs of their own
thinking they can save george's life
they go to his apartment and just
walk inside uninvited they eventually
discovered that he's been experiencing
the same phenomenon that we saw with
eugene in the second movie where he's
just physically unable to kill himself
because it's not his turn
i've been trying to kill myself all day
but it's okay when they tell him that
they saved a janet his attitude
completely changes and it's all
smiles and popping bottles i mean your
best friend still died a horrible death
a couple of hours ago but you're over
that by now right
let me get the cookies after they think
they've beaten death nick and laurie
make plans to travel
similar to alex and clear's idea when
they thought they were in the clear
no pun intended are you sure you don't
want to come to the movie
it's in 3d ooh so meta nick knows it
isn't over yet when he knocks over this
book which reveals
yet another sign i'm not even sure why
he has this book to be honest if it's
just the same paragraph
over and over again the cowboy guy dies
so nick rushes to try to save his
friends with the help of george
who also does this movie came out in
2009 so they couldn't have possibly
known that 2020 would be the deadliest
year since the holocaust making the
address that george died at
all the more mysterious meanwhile his
girlfriend is buying shoes
wait lori don't forget your pamphlet for
two free music
they head to the movie theater where
many of the posters seem to be
additional signs of death the one on the
right is a parody of saving private ryan
the film the girls are going to see is
called lovelace dying which is seen as a
significant sign because lori is nick's
love interest the female lead in
lovelace dying is even named loretta
lori is sometimes used as a nickname for
loretta the image on the poster is an
eye
and when nick sees it on the bus
advertisement we zoom into the eye
the major premonitions from the second
movie forward all end with the camera
zooming out of the visionary's eye one
of the other posters is for a movie
called the death part 2. the fonts and
color scheme looks similar to that of
the final destination remember when i
covered final destination 2 and pointed
out that
hollywood jumps on flight 180 bandwagon
headline my theory is that this
might be the sequel to hollywood's
flight 180 movie there's also an
advertisement on the popcorn tub for an
upcoming movie called still death dewey
part my favorite poster reference is
this one for a sci-fi film called
the z-zone the poster is a parody of the
90s sci-fi television series the x-files
but the connection goes a little deeper
than that
because the screenwriter and jeffrey
reddick once created an x-file script
called flight 180. it was rejected and
redick later adapted it into a feature
film
called final destination the theater
chain is called taggart theaters
according to something i saw in final
destination wiki it was named after
david r ellis's other daughter
taggart inside of the cinema a series of
events unfolds exactly like the events
leading up to the disaster and mckinley
speedway
sir move your feet could you imagine a
theater employee interrupting the movie
to tell shane dawson to move his feet
leave me alone the third parallel took
me a little longer to figure out
a man's ringtone goes off behind laurie
[Music]
to which lori whispers to herself after
looking it up i found out this was a
confederate folk song in america's civil
war
america's civil war was a war against
slavery slavery equals racism the racist
guy from the speedway was sitting in a
similar position in relation to lori as
the ringtone guy and if you go back to
that scene he can be heard whistling the
same melody
sir there would be a couple more final
destination throwbacks as nick tries to
prevent the disaster at tiger theaters
including a fire extinguisher that
shorts out like evans and fd2 and him
being attacked by a nail gun like aaron
and fd3
the movie theater would ultimately not
be the death of nick lori or janet but
the final chronological scene of the
series would offer a few more
connections
and secrets
the first sign that danger is afoot as
nick heads back one last time to the
coffee shop and death by caffeine is the
bus that passes by
bus number 180. then inside the cafe
janet is wearing a hoodie with a cherry
pattern we previously saw cherries on
the necklace of the hairstylist didi and
she was also involved in a major
accident
then the homeless guy who threw away the
lucky penny shows up and starts a
conversation another omen of bad luck
okay that was really weird no there was
nothing weird about that i don't know
why you would call out one of the few
normal moments in this movie they all
sit down together to have a drink
creating a direct parallel to the final
accident in the first final destination
with alex clear and carter like the cafe
miro 81 accidents there's an issue with
a scaffolding and a nearby construction
site and like that scene nick says
essentially what clear said but with
much more pessimistic intentions how do
we know that this isn't exactly what was
meant to happen that out of everyone on
flight 180
you me and carter were meant to live
with us being here
right now was the plan from the
beginning the scaffolds fall into the
street right in between bus 180 and a
sign that says
dead end this would be their dead end
click the video on the left for the next
episode of final destination
things you missed and make sure you're
subscribed to cz's world for
new horrors every week ring the death
bell for notifications and i'll see you
in the next one
assuming we both survive if you want to
be death use a face mask and
social distancing
you